you can see why the nhs is under
pressure we're weeks into the omicron
surge now and that's now being clearly
reflected in hospital admissions
but look on a regional level is there a
glimmer of good news remember london's
omicron wave is a week or two ahead of
other parts of the country today's
estimate from the ons is one in ten
people are infected with omicron in the
capital but look at the latest hospital
admissions and it looks like they might
be reaching a peak in london and so far
at least the severity of illness is
still looking mild with omicron compared
to previous waves those needing
mechanical ventilation just a quarter of
that in previous waves but there's a
massive caveat here the vast majority of
cases so far have been in young people
admissions are still rising among older
people who are more likely to become
severely ill we wait to see how well
boosters protect them good news today
from health officials though in the over
65 boosters still offer about 90
protection from hospitalization three
months after getting one boosters are
probably the main reason we're still not
seeing an increase in deaths so far in
the overcrowd wave at least the nhs may
be struggling but is there good news on
the horizon
we are in a stronger position than we
were this time last year and that's
thanks to the vaccinations the
antivirals the testing we've boosted
more people in this country than in any
other country in europe we've got more
antivirals per head than any other
country in europe we're testing more
people per head than any other country
in europe and that of course is is
helping
one possible guide to what we may see
here is the fuller picture coming in
from south africa this is the latest
data from haoteng province the first to
be hit hard by omicron look at
hospitalizations on the top in dark blue
their wave definitely looks like it's
passing now by no means was it easy a
big rise in hospitalizations
but on par or lower than with previous
waves of infections despite much higher
infection rates and take a look at
mortality at the bottom here in red far
fewer deaths from orocron despite pretty
high levels of hospital admissions
big caveats here of course south africa
has a much younger population than we do
and high levels of immunity from
previous waves
hidden in the uk data might be another
bit of good news for us cases of the
delta variant here in red
are finally on the way down the uptake
of boosters the most likely explanation
omicron in blue definitely has the
potential to cause huge suffering but if
our response to it is helping snuff out
the definitely more dangerous delta that
can only be a good thing